be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so a Suicide Squad right around the
corner what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Amanda Waller from the
new 52 now what I'm hoping is that at
the end of all this you'll have a good
idea of her character as well as why
she's remained such a fearsome member of
DC's landscape throughout our
publication history in DC's reboot and
so within the new 52 much like most of
DC's lineup safer Batman and Green
Lantern Amanda Waller received a
wholesale relaunch that canceled out the
entirety of her continuity prior to the
series launch making her debut within
the pages of Team seven issue number one
in 2012 DC continued the trend of
depicting Amanda Waller without an
origin story of her own instead DC look
to the team seven line of stories as a
way to reintroduce her to the reading
audience using a familiar landscape and
her place within the DC Universe
Josiah check for second because the new
52 saw DC role and their ancillary
publications of vertigo and Wildstorm
into the fold and creating a wholly new
universe by combining the various
characters and teams from these
publications with their own roster of
titles with team seven serving as a
Wildstorm imprint designed to operate as
a strike force team not unlike Nick
Fury's Howling Commandos the newly
included line of publications served as
a perfect home for the introduction of
Amanda Waller as the hidden hand behind
a multitude of concepts within DC's
comics however somebody to take note of
here is that not only had Amanda Waller
never received her own origin story but
her history within the DC new 52 is far
less complex and less intricate than it
was in the pre new 52 continuity instead
under the writing of Justin Jordan team
7 focus on a behind the scenes backstory
to the events leading up to the
introductions of characters in the new
52 and the basis behind Amanda Waller's
creation of The Suicide Squad a covered
in issue number zero titled the majestic
seven as part of DC zero month which
provided origins for their teams and
characters in the new 52 what we're told
is that with the world becoming aware of
Superman and other heroes with
tremendous power the federal government
looked to organize a team that could
prevent future metahuman threats as well
as monitor those beings who are
perceived to be possible threats to this
end and under the direction of John
Lynch team 7 was organized and consisted
of a mishmash of DC and wasallam
characters including Black Canary death
stroke amanda waller cold - James
Robinson and Steve Trevor improving
herself to be highly capable in terms of
her knowledge of espionage strategy
weapons use and military tactics team
seven largely faced off against
small-time villains and metahuman
threats including former Arkham Asylum
researchers who created zombies in their
attempts to turn insane criminals Saint
as well as a clip so the God of
vengeance who was initially introduced
within the pages of Red Hood and The
Outlaws and temporarily possessed
Deathstroke while the series only ran
for around seven issues due to the fact
that fan interest was confined to the
backstory of the new 52 which dissipated
once the original story arc ended the
role of Amanda Waller jumped forward by
five years to the official start of the
new 52 and the introduction of Suicide
Squad company Suicide Squad issue number
zero with team seven being cancelled
before writer Justin Jordan was able to
completely flesh out and disband the
team Suicide Squad writer adam glass use
issue number zero to wrap around to the
conclusion of team seven establishing
that the group had been set on a mission
to retrieve Pandora's box an artifact
based on the mythological object of the
same name and containing all the world's
evils during their attempts to capture
the artifact the store revealed that the
true goal of team seven was to display
their capabilities against metahumans
with select members of being granted
powers as a result and during their
final mission a freak accident occurred
involving the sonic scream of Black
Canary and a wave of psychic energy that
melded the minds of Caze and Gamora and
agent Higgins leaving the two to adopt
the moniker of Regulus with Regulus
taking over the criminal underground
organization called basilisk Amanda
Waller assembled the remains of Team
seven to eliminate Regulus and prevent
his acquisition of a nuclear weapon
however during the fight
Regulus mutated the entirety of Wohlers
team forcing her to kill all of them
after which she came to the conclusion
that a team needed to be formed which
could carry out the same role as team
seven but consisting of disposable
members presenting her plan to her
superiors
Amanda Waller Suicide Squad was formed
using criminals from DC's Bellerive
prison who were coerced onto the team
through force or blackmail and served to
both eliminate metahuman threats to the
world as well as secure and ensured
humanity's dominance of her metahuman
technology originally consisting of
Harley Quinn king shark black spider
el Diablo Sivan two voltaic and Deadshot
as the team's field commander prior to
their initiation into the team Waller
put the group through a series of
rigorous forms of physic
and psychological torture designed to
test the limits of what they could
withstand as well as our loyalty to the
team what the roster contained in issue
number one displaying those who passed
the test in truth the Suicide Squad line
of comics served as a platform for
Harley Quinn's popularity in the new 52
leading to her eventual solo series
while this wasn't the intention of DC as
far as I'm aware because Harley had been
such a popular character following her
introduction to Batman the Animated
Series and her subsequent appearances
bladder Adam glass built off the concept
by developing Harley's own story within
the series building fan interests for
her solo series in 2014 where her
departure and issue number five fell in
line with the revolving door theme of
the team DC hoped to use the popularity
of the title with Harley Quinn as a way
to keep existing fans on board by
continuing compelling stories and
teasing various villains who could
continue interest however the opposite
effect happened in that a majority of
readers departed the series for Harley
Quinn solo comic in 2014 meaning that
the Suicide Squad line was cancelled
after 30 issues however for the
character of Amanda Waller over the
course of her time in Suicide Squad her
character was depicted as cold ruthless
and highly intelligent expressing
virtually no remorse over the fact that
despite their criminal past the members
of the squad were still people instead
Waller viewed them as expendable assets
designed to serve a purpose and to be
dismissed
once that purpose was completed in
addition to this where glass kept these
themes of Amanda Waller within the pages
of Suicide Squad because the pre new 52
depiction of her character saw her
involved in a multitude of agencies and
organizations during the new 52 DC
looked to achieve the same goal with her
character to this end with issue number
19 Amanda Waller was removed from the
Suicide Squad line by Adam glass and
replaced with the Unknown Soldier
following this Waller was spun out into
a series of appearances including Teen
Titans Justice League of America Green
Lantern and forever evil even going so
far as to become the temporary head of
Argus the advanced research group
uniting superhumans not a side track for
a second where Argus was originally
launched in the new 52 under the
direction of Steve Trevor
owing to both his military record and
romance with Wonder Woman with the
Justice League's first story arc against
Darkseid serving as the basis behind the
organization's formation after the
conclusion of the storyline villains
journey which centred on the league
facing off against the villain named
David graves Steve Trevor was removed
from his position as director of Argus
due to the idea that the organization
needed a more aggressive stance
following the league's near defeat with
Amanda Waller being appointed to the
position in addition to using the
organization as a means to attempt to
take down the basilisk a terrorist cell
her efforts extended to reaching out to
David graves putting his extreme
intelligence to the test by way of
commissioning a book on how to take down
the Justice League however with Amanda
Waller's time proven to be disastrous
and that her efforts to subdue criminal
organisations and preventing the events
are forever evil from taking place all
failed she was removed from the position
and Steve Trevor was reinstated leading
into the events of her every evil proper
as part of DC's road to darkside war
where Amanda Waller was largely isolated
to the background but following the
events conclusion in 2014 under the
Riding of Sean Ryan the new Suicide
Squad was launched and originally
consisting of Black Manta
Deadshot Deathstroke Harley Quinn and
Joker's daughter while this return to
familiarity was twofold and that Amanda
Waller seemed to fit at home with a team
the second half of this equation was
shifting up the status quo by placing
Amanda Waller under the direction of
Victor stage functioning as a de facto
head of Suicide Squad but maintaining
loyalty to his corporate backers staged
a lot to transform the Suicide Squad
into a Heroes for Hire s team that could
be financed and lent out to various
agencies from around the world allowing
them to use the squad for their own
calls of corporate or international
espionage taking the team underground
and subverting the actions of Victor
staged the efforts of Amanda Waller
resulted in sages corruption becoming
public forcing the government to remove
him from his position and placing it
under the complete authority of Waller
herself that said as far as I've been
able to tell with the Suicide Squad
expected to receive the DC rebirth
treatment on August 3rd it's unknown how
the team's revamp will impact Amanda
Waller if at all but assuming that all
the existing trends remain true Waller
will likely return to her classical pre
new 52 roots in terms of both their
mannerisms and her appearance with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to in it I hope you guys enjoyed it and
just out of curiosity let me know how
you guys feel down in the comments about
Viola Davis playing Amanda Waller
because I personally think there could
not have been a better choice she looks
amazing and I will catch you guys on her
peace